- Alright everybody welcome
to another YouTube hangout.
Super excited to be back
with my friend Stephen Kelly,
the CEO of the best accounting
software in the world, Sage.
We had a month off.
We some technical difficulties
or just scheduling issues last month.
But we've got two happening in June.
And today we're going to talk about
how to stand out with your customers.
Stephen, welcome back.
- Hey, great to be here Evan.
Love these hangouts, so it's always cool.
Even just to be in your
company 3,000 miles away,
Evan, lights up my day.
- I love it.
Well, I'm excited for this topic.
But before that, I heard
just before going on
that you are starting a vlog,
and the first one comes out today.
- Yeah, yeah.
Well I just thought, you know,
obviously, Sage is a big company,
great technology company,
largest tech company in the
UK, all those good things.
And actually, amazingly,
our customers, Evan,
my guys told me this, manage
or move money around the world
to the equivalent of about
four trillion U.S. dollars.
So it's like, massive.
It's probably twice the
size of the Canadian GDP.
Gross domestic product.
- That's crazy.
- But we feel like the
world's most exciting
and yet the biggest startup.
That's the way we think.
And I just thought,
wouldn't it be great if
everybody who's kind of
one of your followers
and the folks out there,
aspiring entrepreneurs, grafters,
who want to build a business,
follow their dreams.
What about if I kind of gave 'em
a day in the life of Stephen Kelly?
Just run a kind of video
diary that we kind of post.
And so that's what we're starting.
We're starting a vlog,
and actually, when I come out and meet you
we'd have to do special
editions and stuff like that.
When I'm in Toronto.
Maybe even go to a Blue Jays game, yeah?
- I like it.
- And I love that.
Kind of September, October
and Blue Jays kick off.
I think it'd be interesting
to see what are the,
'cause it must seem I suppose,
you know what it's like
being an entrepreneur
from the outside seems pretty glamorous,
but when you're there in the
heat of the daily battles,
the ups and downs, the sort
of daily roller coaster,
that everybody, all your
followers experience,
it can feel very
different from the inside.
So, I want to give people
a kind of uncut version
of what's it like to me a chief executive
or what's a 31,550 company,
one of the biggest companies
in terms of technology around the world.
So that's the purpose.
And what I should say is, obviously,
love all your followers to
pick up and look at the vlog,
and we'll post it later today.
But also love feedback, two way feedback.
So, if you guys want me
to cover different things,
or you don't think it's
useful or whatever,
I really want to make sure there's content
in there that helps people, entrepreneurs,
just overcome any fears
and make good decisions
and grow their businesses and expand.
- Very cool.
I'm excited to see it.
The audience is already excited,
we're getting people writing in,
Dash: "So excited," all
caps, "to see this duo again.
"I always intake so
much vital information."
So I'm pumped to get it going.
Now, before I get into the topic,
people always love the Stephen
Kelly quotes to kick us off,
so we've been waiting for a month.
What do you have for us, Stephen?
Give us some good quotes.
- I've got some pretty cool quotes.
Obviously, one of the legends
around technology at Apple, Steve Jobs.
So Steve captures some
of the essence, he says,
"Get closer than ever to your customers.
"So close that you can
tell them what they need
"well before they realize it themselves."
And obviously he did that
with the iPhone and stuff like that.
Brilliant, brilliant innovation.
And music.
So next one, another
great, amazing entrepreneur
at Amazon, Jeff Bezos.
And obviously he says,
and he's built incredible
culture around customers,
"We see customers as
invited guests to our party.
"And we are the hosts.
"It is our job everyday to
make every important aspect
"toward the customer experience
just a little bit better."
And then this is so
true, and you know this,
and I know this, is a great
quote from the Sage himself.
The Sage Warren Buffet.
- Nice.
- I like that, I like
that, he is the Sage.
The ultimate investor Sage.
And anybody who doesn't
know him, check him out.
Warren Buffet, Google him.
Probably the most legendary
investor of the last 50 years.
And still incredibly strong.
And he says, which is
great, and we know this,
"It takes 20 years to build a reputation.
"And five minutes to ruin it.
"If you think about that,
"then you'll do things differently."
So I think kind of
three quotes to kick off
from amazing learners
is Warren, Jeff Bezos
and Steve Jobs just to
kind of get it going.
But this customer
experience and standing out
from customers is the essence
of a brilliant business
where your idea or
product really builds love
from the customers point of view.
So I think it's a great topic
and it's great also, Evan,
probably, to say that
your viewers are the guys
who made this topic for us.
So, I hope we're going to
give you in this hangout
some really fantastic material.
How your businesses can really
stand out for your customers.
- I love it.
Well before getting into the questions
that are already popping
up in the live chat,
what are your overall thoughts,
what are your top line
kind of overall advice,
big three things that
entrepreneurs need to do
to stand out with their customers?
- I think something we've said all along,
you've got to put yourselves
in the shoes of the customers.
You've got to live, and breathe,
and go where your audience is.
And then you got to do things
really intelligent around what is the need
that you're serving for your customers?
What is it they need or want?
And then the big thing around this topic
is how do you do it so differently
that they'll remember that forever?
How do you make their
lives so much better?
And how do you differentiate yourself?
You build massive early
massive loyalty, fanaticism.
We want your customers
to be fanatical for you
and feel love for your brand
and your product and your service.
So, I think they're the things.
Now number one, sit in the
shoes of your customers.
Secondly, really think
about what is it they want,
they need, to be successful.
And then the big thing
is how do you stand out?
How do you differentiate yourself?
Why are you different?
Why are you the must-have product
that they'll rave about to their friends
when they go to a college
party, or whatever?
- I'm wondering, in my
own personal interest,
for Sage, what do you guys go?
And I know you personally,
every time you go traveling,
you have to go and talk to customers,
you make that a priority to go
and meet some of the customers,
but what are some of the ways
that Sage as a business,
or you personally,
work to try to stand
out with your customers?
- Yeah, so kind of what we think about
is everything actually,
from the planning process
for the company, through
to the daily activity,
always says, what is it for the customer?
Where is the customer
in this conversation?
And it's so easy.
I'd say this, it's so
easy for big companies
to start kind of becoming
sort of naval gazing,
internally focused,
whatever words you use,
like analysis paralysis.
And it's easy for, particularly
everybody will know this,
if you've been in a big company,
there's some people who get
a bit complacent, a bit comfortable.
And what you need, you
as the entrepreneurs,
is to always have that
kind of shock therapy,
where everything's always
about the customer.
And sometimes you can be
extreme, and I do it here,
little symbolic things, like
if we're on an internal meeting
with marketing and product development,
I'll keep a chair free for the customer.
I'll turn around, and I'll say,
here's a customer that
they're in a plumbing business
or they're in a digital marketing agency,
and they're fast growing.
What are the things they're
going to be worried about
that we can really address
in this conversation?
And then I think the
other thing, as you scale
and grow your businesses, all
the entrepreneurs out there,
and you hire your tenth employee,
and your 15th, employ 20,
you want to inject that
everything you build
has to be centered around
the customers you serve.
And even things like in
the recruitment process,
make that explicit.
When they join, you do
some sort of onboard,
induction, whatever you want to call it,
and again, make sure it's explicit around
the value you're driving
to your customers,
and why you're different,
so they kind of get it.
'Cause what you want is really,
it's kind of mother and
apple pie to say so, Evan,
you want your colleagues,
the people who work
in your company, to be
the biggest advocates
and the biggest ambassadors
for your product,
'cause you want them to tell your friends
that you're a great business,
you got amazing vision,
you got a great idea, you're
going to change the world.
'Cause you want them to
attract their friends
and recruit more people and
more customers and partners.
So I think the essence is,
the question, Evan, is,
everything you do from getting
up first thing in the morning
to going to bed, everything
whether it's planning,
strategic, everything's got to
be centered on the customer.
And ultimately providing
massive differentiation
and value to the customer
on a sustainable basis
for them to be successful.
- I love it, I love it.
Dropping some wisdom
bombs right off the start.
First question's coming in from J Rise,
who's asking about your blog.
So it's not a blog, it's a vlog, right?
It's a video version, right?
- Yeah, yeah, much easier.
- And they want to know where the link is.
It's just going to be on
the Sage YouTube channel?
- Yeah, and I'll post
it on all the channels,
obviously things like Twitter as well.
So I'll post that.
So if you guys would follow
me, it should be on the screen,
but @SKellyCEO.
Then you'll get it coming
out today, I'll post it.
And I'll post it to all my
channels as well, Instagram,
Facebook, and also Twitter
and stuff like that.
So, that'd be good and it's video,
'cause this is kind of a related topic.
We think video, and actually
the channel on YouTube
is unbelievable for you
guys to really market
and sell your products, and your brand,
and why you're different.
And we think video is just an amazing way
people consume technology choices,
ideas, and all these sort of things.
And this is kind of a
digression, actually,
but it's kind of interesting,
Evan, I think you were there.
We had Chad Hurley, who is the co-founder
and CEO of YouTube when it started.
- Yep.
- And I was sitting in
the Sage Summit back in,
I think it was New Orleans,
and we talked to Chad about
his dream for YouTube.
And I think at the time he said, "Well,
"we would have been blown away if we'd had
"like 20,000 YouTube subscribers,
"and we thought if people
could post hundreds
"of video pieces a day,
that'd be incredible."
And that would've been success.
And I think I read something
even six months ago,
there's like 400 hours of content
being posted every minute.
So we just think that
the level of consumption
by both consumers and,
actually, business people
around video content, is great.
So this vlog,
my mission is I'd kind of
do it probably, initially,
every two weeks.
And it's no more than five
or six, seven minutes.
So, it's very easy to consume.
And we'll probably have to make sure,
when we have a special moment Evan,
we capture it on the vlog.
- Yeah, I'm excited.
And for those of you guys watching,
I've been talking to Stephen
about video for awhile.
I remember way back on
one of our first hangouts,
one of our audience
members couldn't make it
because they were doing cancer treatment,
and Stephen ended up at the airport
making a quick little video on his phone
wishing that person good luck,
and hope the treatment goes well,
and we'll see you hopefully
at the next episode.
And I thought it was a
really cool thing to do for,
you know, you've got this CEO,
who's got 13, 14, 15 thousand employees
and taking out time out of his day
to make a custom video.
And so I think he could do
really well on the vlog,
and I'm excited that that's coming out.
Okay, let's get to some questions.
They've been piling up
as we've been talking.
The first is from Sharique who's asking,
"How do you surround
yourself with great people
"who care about the customers?"
- That's a great question.
Do you know what one of the things
you can do in the early days?
Is probably hiring your
company a customer.
Or someone who lives,
and walks, and breathes
the customer journey everyday.
And the other things we kind of do,
which I think's pretty cool,
is have things like
entrepreneurs in residence.
So, we have Nicole Harding,
who's come into Sage to work for us.
And they're entrepreneurs,
they're grafters,
they started their business and
they've walked in the shoes,
and they've done maybe
three or four businesses
where they've done start
ups and grown 'em up,
have done an exit, gone
on to the next one.
So, I think the other
thing is, in reality,
loads of things that we
sort of touched on is
make sure you as the
entrepreneur and the founder
talk always about customers,
and you will very much,
by that, you will attract
similar individuals
who really care passionately
about customers.
And then the other thing I
think is a really good idea,
if it's achievable, is you
actually join the communities
of your customers, and you
can do that on social media.
But also I'd always
advocate, if you can without
crossing the line in terms
of upsetting customers,
if you can recruit customers
into your business,
you'll understand, obviously
the customer perspective,
but also understand how to scale
and grow your business as well.
That's a fantastic lens for you
to have within your company.
- That's interesting.
I'm curious what you
guys do with customers.
So you have some of them who
sit in on board meetings,
or who advise you guys,
or have you hired them
away from their business
and now they're working
in side stage on different projects?
- Yeah, we've got a number of things.
Actually, I think you
met some of these guys.
We got this Sage Ambassadors program,
so we've got business experts.
And I go out all by myself
probably every month
and meet up country by country,
and meet the local
management team at Sage,
talk about issues relevant
to the customer journey.
And also I tend to check
in with those guys.
The other things we do
is have these kind of
conceptive entrepreneurs in residence,
where they come in and kind of
help us understand more about
what are the pain points
and gain points that customers see.
And then also, yeah, we have taken on
some folks, I mentioned Nicole.
There's a few folks, a
lot of folks actually,
in the company who have been
entrepreneurs themselves,
and come to work for Sage,
because there's no better perspective
than having kind of done
it, and worn the T-shirt,
and started a couple of companies.
And also, Evan, not only companies
that have been successful,
but some of the best
learnings you get is when
you hit the skids, and you have a failure.
And you have to exit prematurely,
or you don't realize your dreams,
because, inevitably, the reality is
there's something fantastic in the U.S.,
there's millions of
businesses start every year.
Over in the U.K. there's about
600,000 new businesses started last year.
But within five years probably,
60% of those would have failed.
I don't like that word failure,
'cause if you fail and you fail fast,
that's probably the best learnings
you're ever going to
get as an entrepreneur.
And you can go on a greater,
fantastically successful
business next time.
- I love it.
And thinking about
attracting a great team,
I would say too, that when
you stand for something,
it's easy to get the
right people on board.
If it's really clear in
all of your messaging
and all your activities that
you care about the customer,
you're going to attract people
who care about the customers.
If people are applying to Sage,
and they see Stephen
on his vlog interacting
with the customers and
continuing to care about them,
then the people who like
that are going to be the ones
who also believe in the same thing.
And so if you're really
clear about your mission,
what you stand for,
what you're here to do,
and if serving customer
needs is your mission,
then you're going to attract people
who want to be a part of that.
If it's unclear what you stand for,
then if you're hiring a programmer,
or customer service representative,
or whoever into your business,
you're going to get all
kinds of different people.
And so you want to be
really upfront and clear
what your mission is so
attract like-minded people,
and the people who don't
agree with your mission,
they're never going to apply.
So, they self-eliminate from the start.
Great, let's get to some more.
So, Dash is writing in,
"How would you suggest
"being successful with limited resources?
"Do you believe in your
character, personality, and
"or values driving the business
"as opposed to the equipment you own?"
- Yeah, Dash, that's a great question,
and I think we'd probably also say
it's all about leadership,
it's your personality.
You are the expression of the idea.
All the product you sell.
And we talk about the integrity
that you have, the love,
the dream, and the
inspiration and the vision
that you can not only
inspire your customers,
maybe partners, but also people who work
for you in the business colleagues.
That's really, really fundamental.
And the personality is really important.
So, I think there's a lot
of things you as a leader,
when you want to stand out, it's so easy
to be swayed by a lot of people.
And I think if you have a
really strong conviction,
and to Evan's point, hashtag believe,
then how do you stand out from the crowd?
We stand in the shoes of the customer.
You've got the big ideas,
so I think there's a whole theme around,
obviously you want to
listen to the colleagues,
you want to listen to the
market really carefully,
but you also got to be confident
and be decisive and make those calls.
And then put a lot of the
word behind the few hours
and really focus on being successful.
And I'd always encourage you
to have that beginners mind.
Be different, think differently,
think about the next thing,
what is it, especially in the
word of disintermediation,
customers will, in five years time,
be doing that you can invent today.
So, do think differently,
and I think a lot
of that comes from, as you said,
it's your personality, and make your brand
very visible in terms of your personality
and your leadership,
'cause that will inspire
all the important people
like the customers
and especially your colleagues.
If you get those two right,
you've got a fantastic business.
- What was the analogy you used?
Focus on the wood behind your few arrows?
Is that what you said?
- Oh. Yeah, yeah.
So, this is kind of, this is crazy.
This is not a metaphor
for the digital age.
But when you're an entrepreneur,
one of the biggest problems
you have is prioritization.
Hey, this is really interesting,
apparently prioritize, I think
it comes from a Greek word.
And you know how we say,
"What are your top four priorities?"
Well, that actually breaches
the essence of the Greek word.
Prioritize means you
can only do one thing.
Uno. One thing.
No more.
You can't do two priorities,
three priorities.
So it's ruthless, and obviously,
in a modern age, we
have lots of priorities.
The biggest challenge
we have as entrepreneurs
is that single focus around the thing
that's really going to move
the needle, move the dart.
And so we have this phrase
as, you can have 50 arrows
out there, and go to 50 markets,
and try and do 50 different things,
or generate and create
14 different products.
We'd say, no, no, no.
Have a big vision, but then day to day
for the first 90 days, put
all the wood behind one arrow.
One arrow, as in
(whooshing sound)
bows and arrows and
all that sort of stuff.
- Yeah, yeah.
- And get all the wood on those arrows.
So you put approach huge critical mass.
And they create a beachhead
where you've got momentum,
you've got fanatical customers,
and then you use that
love to actually go on
to the next beachhead, and
then the next beachhead,
and then the next.
Honestly, my experience of entrepreneurs,
we are so optimistic, we are so excited,
we are so into our idea.
And yet sometimes we've
just got to check ourselves,
and instead trying to be
all things to all people,
we should be brilliant
at one thing at a time.
And then that can build a great company.
- I like it.
I've never head that expression
before, so I like it.
It's good, it's good.
Extra ammunition to play with there.
To the question of limited resources,
I mean, that's entrepreneurship.
You never have all the
resources that you need.
That's why you go out
and create something new
and innovative, because you're
forced up against a wall
to find another way to stand.
I think what really helped me
when I was first getting
started was recognizing that
people that I looked up to,
the people that I aspired
to have that kind of impact,
some of the people behind me on the wall,
they started with less than
what I already have right now.
The people who you look up
to, and you want to be like,
the titans in your industry,
look at their story,
and look at how they started.
Chances are it wasn't just handed to them,
and they started off with less
than what you already have right now.
And so I use that as motivation to say,
these guys could do it, I can do it too.
And instead of seeing limited resources
as a complaining point, use
that as your opportunity.
That's where you have a chance
to do something different and stand out.
That's the game. That's entrepreneurship.
You will have limited resources.
- I love it.
- You got to use them wisely.
Put the wood behind the few arrows.
- I love it.
(Evan laughing)
Hey, you're going to love this,
Evan, you're going to love this.
So, one thing I talk a lot about here is,
and you'll love this,
you can have this quote,
"The answer is never more resources.
"The answer is always
more resourcefulness."
And that's why entrepreneurs
are hugely successful.
They always overcome difficulties.
There are never any excuses.
They always touch the stars.
I think we got to save
that quote for next time,
you'll lead us off with it.
That's a good one.
Yeah, it reminds me of Steve Wozniak,
who co-founded Apple, who said,
"Stop thinking about the
resources that you don't have,
"and instead think about what you can do
"with what you do have."
And I think once you change
your mindset from just being
complaining, or desperate, or upset,
to a positive one, okay
I have something here,
let's use what I have to build it.
That's when you start
becoming more successful.
So, I like it.
Next, Randy is writing in,
"Hi Stephen, it's Randy.
"I own a resort on an island.
"Should I act on all the feedback
"from my customers, and
should I encourage feedback?"
- Yeah, I think Randy, if you own a resort
you need to ping Evan and me an invite.
We'd love that.
(laughing)
So, I think just thinking
of what people like,
obviously people like Trip Advisor,
but there's just tons of social sites
where everything is about reviews
and obviously, seeing what
people like Airbnb have done,
and all those other
guys, I think you're in
a super, almost transparent marketplace.
And that's obviously
fueled by social media.
And I think, just looking at ConsumerLink,
the data point is about 70% of people now
kind of bought resorts and stuff online.
The old kind of model
going through things like
travel agents and stuff
is pretty redundant.
And the really important
thing is this is where,
and this is so important, customer love.
How do we inspire customer
love in terms of resort?
And I think a message for
entrepreneurs I'd always give is,
if you can just do every little thing,
every little interaction, like
the book-in, the reservation,
the welcome, the room, the breakfast,
whatever it is you do when you break down
the whole journey for a customer.
And break it down to every component.
Every touch point, every
moment of their day.
If you just exceed their
expectations just by a little bit,
then you will be remembered
forever by that individual.
And I think the other thing we forget,
it's like a resort vacation,
is wow, if it goes well,
typically you don't get
a level of fanaticism.
If it goes exceptionally well,
they'll tell maybe five people.
If it goes badly, they'll
tell a hundred people.
So, the cons are stacked against you
on the downside if you get it wrong.
Now, I would say also that
I think authenticity is really important.
I get customers, we got wow,
three million customers,
businesses around the
world use our technology.
Do we get it right every day
of the week, every second?
Absolutely not.
Do we drop the ball? Yeah.
And when we do that, I'll
get customers DMing me,
emailing me, calling me, and I'll say wow,
my aspiration is that
we have the happiest,
and most delighted, and raving fanatical,
incredibly advocates out
there, but we drop the ball.
Sometimes the product say
doesn't work, or the internet
it would connect in or the
cloud went down, whatever.
There's some stuff, just stuff happens.
So, what I do in those situations,
and you could really do
this powerfully in a resort,
when stuff goes wrong, the
visibility of you, Randy,
as the leader, picking up the phone,
calling on their cellphone at that moment,
having a record response
team, sorting it out,
making them whole, and
you might get a bowl
of fruit delivered to their room
or whatever it is, is very powerful.
And then the other thing I'd say is
when they go back, they
come back to say Toronto,
or Vancouver, or
Minneapolis two weeks later.
You know how it is on a
vacation, this is interesting.
When you have a vacation
you have the best time
in the world, and you talk about dreams
and all that sort of stuff,
and you have really sort of
these esoteric conversations
with your partner or your friends.
When you get back, within
six hours of getting back,
you feel like you haven't had a vacation.
Do you have that feeling?
Like wow, I've just been
away for two weeks in Hawaii,
and I'm back here, and
wow, just my emails,
my inbox, I'm overwhelmed, it's crazy,
I can't see the wood from the trees.
And it feel like you haven't
had a vacation at all.
Now, how powerful would it be, Randy,
if two weeks after that person's
vacation on your resort,
when something went wrong,
they got a bouquet of flowers
to send we're really
sorry, we dropped the ball,
we hope you had an amazing time.
'Cause they'd remember you forever,
and they would be your advocates.
'Cause it is just about
those little moment of magic
that you create where you give them
an experience that blows their brain.
- I love it.
That extra love. I love it.
So, Randy is from Trinidad,
the island's on Trinidad,
and he's writing in
that he's writing all of
this stuff down, he's loving your advice.
Randy, I would say I would
split into two things.
One, there's the algorithmic
marketing side of things
with your Google Reviews
and your Trip Advisor
and Expedia reviews, and all the new game
that you have to play because
when people are booking
they want to see that you
have positive reviews.
So yes, incentivizing your
customers to leave reviews
and share their honest opinions,
that will help you with new marketing.
But on the other side is just
providing a great experience.
Everything Stephen's been talking about.
I would study Steve Wynn, I would study
the Four Seasons Hotel,
the classic story of
somebody left their bags at your hotel,
and they went to the
airport, and the bell hop
gets the bags and follows them in the cab,
and delivers them at the
airport to them, right?
Just looking for extra ways.
If somebody asks for
directions to the pool,
don't just tell them, take them
to the pool, and show them.
Every little touch point,
everything Stephen was saying,
to try to make it a memorable experience,
to turn that one off I'm
going to go to Trinidad
and check out this new resort,
versus every winter I'm going
to this resort in Trinidad,
and I'm bringing my whole family with me
because these guys get it
and have the best service.
If you give them that amazing experience,
they're going to want
to come back every year,
tell their friends about it as well.
- Yeah, on that, Evan, I think it's right
to the subject, how do you stand out?
I think this is a great area where Randy,
especially if you're in
that beautiful island,
Trinidad and Tobago.
I love the Caribbean.
You can really sit down and think about,
based on all the reviews,
number one is kind of any
entrepreneur would say,
what market am I going
for, where is the audience?
And I think this is where
you can be really honest.
So maybe, I don't know,
maybe your market is
20 to 30 year olds, maybe it's travelers,
maybe it's families.
So, where these kind of
particularly resorts get it wrong is
when they start mixing up the audiences.
So, you get young families,
and then you get party animals
and 25 year olds going
on spring break parties.
That's going to be a disaster.
'Cause no one's going to be happy.
'Cause the guys that
want to go out all night,
and drink all night, and party all night,
will be waking up all the families.
So, you need to really say,
what is the market I'm serving?
Who is the segment?
Is it families?
Is it what generation, what nationality?
You know, you can get really granular.
And then I think people really
appreciate honesty as well,
so on your website you should say, look,
if you're a young family, you're
probably not going to have
a great experience here
'cause this is a party resort.
Yeah, but if you're 18 to 30 years old,
and you want to have the
best time of your life,
this is the resort for you.
And then you really meet the market,
and everything's steelpans
when they get to the resort,
all the great music that
comes from the Caribbean,
all the fantastic stuff,
cocktails on the beach,
rum punches, all that sort of stuff's
where you're very much
differentiating yourself,
making yourself different
from the kind of big brands.
So you can create a unique
experience for your customers
to really meet their needs and wants.
And they go away feeling like
they've been sitting with
Bob Marley for two weeks
and experiencing the real Caribbean.
So, I think you can do that,
and then I would advocate
really to what Evan said even more,
that you want to get
that social listening.
And actually on this area,
there's some brilliant social
listening tools you can get
where not only do people write reviews,
but there's stuff you
don't see that they write
in other places where you can get
a pulse of what's going on.
And I'd absolutely say that.
And if there's stuff out there,
the best thing you can
do as an entrepreneur
is know about it yourself.
The worst thing you can have happen to you
is for someone to denigrate
your brand, or your product,
or your resort and not tell you about it.
If they tell you about it,
you've got every opportunity to fix it.
And with these things, you
know this as consumers,
when you fix stuff for
customers, when they go wrong,
that's when you see great companies.
Great companies always will make mistakes,
but when great companies make
mistakes, they step up tall,
they stand shoulder to
shoulder with the customer,
and they fix it and
make the customer whole.
- I love it.
Paula and Peter, we're
coming to you guys next,
but I just have a follow
up question for Stephen.
I agree with everything you say.
You're going to have some
people thinking, okay,
even though I get most my
business from the party crowd,
I don't want to lose the families,
because my place isn't full,
and so I don't want to turn away business.
What do you say, how do you
respond to that reaction?
- I think the beauty of
a resort-type business,
the economics is all about utilization.
And then once you've got the utilization,
that probably covers your cost.
And then the profitability you make is
through a food, beverage,
all those sort of things.
So, there's a number of options you have
in a resort business, I
wouldn't intend to be an expert,
but you can look at times of the year.
You could have the same
resort in vacations,
like Christmas vacation, all families.
And then you could say, right,
now we're in mid-January,
on to middle of February,
you could just say it's
going to be party resort,
and you could actually change the spaces
and the areas to
accommodate your audience.
What I would say is you
kind of don't want to mix up
in the same locality different people
with different needs,
and it's all the case.
Evan's got kids, I've got kids,
what I wanted to do when I was 21
was very different when
I was 35 with kids.
So, I think the other thing,
if you've got a big resort,
then you could have the latitude
to have different spaces
for different audiences.
Again, it comes back to
really what is the audience
you're serving, what is the segment?
And then how do you
leverage your property,
your resort, to do that best?
And then also look at
the times of the year.
You'll get very different people coming
to the Caribbean during
hurricane season than you will do
in that kind of January,
February, March period.
So, I think it could be different.
And the other thing, actually
Evan, this is different.
When you have loads of resorts, do this.
When you have off-peak times,
and I think you're right,
you need the utilization,
you need the occupancy,
then you can probably target
specialist interest groups.
So, you could do yoga weeks,
or you could do Pilates,
and you could have a
completely different audience
and make sure that the
resorts kit it out for that.
But that's a great way in low occupancy,
and in bad off-season
times, to keep the occupancy
up with different communities.
But it all comes back to who you serve,
and what's the audience
need, what are their wants,
and how do you excel at them?
- Yeah, and I think
sometimes you just have
to turn away the wrong customer.
If it's not a fit for you.
If all Sage had was Sage One,
which is the kind of entry level package,
you're not going to go to IBM and say,
hey, buy our Sage One
software, it's just not a fit.
It's not going to be a great
experience for anybody.
And so yes, it might
bring short-term revenue
into your business, but
there's going to be complaints,
you're going to get
negative scores everywhere,
it's going to be a hassle for your staff,
all your customers are going
to be unsatisfied with it.
And so if you understand who
your ideal target market is,
then just go strong after them
and give them the best
possible experience.
That means, to Stephen's
point about prioritizing,
and the Greek word, and
coming down the one thing,
it means that some customers
are not going to be perfect fits
for your business, and that's okay.
'Cause if you try to appeal to everybody,
it means you're going to
strongly appeal to nobody.
Let's hit up Paula.
Paula: "I have a question!"
Exclamation point.
"When your client
portfolio grows to a point
"where you realize that you need help,
"what tasks do you believe are critical
"for you to continue handling yourselves?"
So, she's struggling to kind of grow.
It's a good place to be,
congratulations, Paula.
She's grown her client portfolio
to a certain size, and she needs help.
What should she be looking for,
and how should she be spending her time?
- Yeah, I think it's a
great question, Paula.
And obviously, Paula, congratulations
on the growth of your business.
That's fantastic.
I'd say things that really matter
is things that touch the customer.
Typically you'll find, Paula, you'll know
are you a really customer oriented,
customer experience, sales
marketing type person?
Or are you like a product genius?
Like a Steve Jobs.
Where you really have the ideas.
You rarely find the same person
with both sets of skills,
so you may surround
yourself, you typically have
partnerships started
where you've got someone
who's very externally
focused and someone who does
either all the back
office, all the inventing.
What I would say is the first
areas you should look to
bring in other folks, which
should be very easy towards me,
is things like what we call
the back office finance,
paying your taxes.
And obviously we've got a
great network of people like
accountants and bookkeepers
who can help you with that.
And you typically pay them
a retain or an annual fee
and they do all the billing,
invoicing, cash collection,
all those sort of things, to make sure
you've got great cash
flow in your business.
The other things that then
you can start thinking about
is on some of the really specialist areas,
which are really cool and do
give you big differentiation.
And I'll pick out one area
like that is digital marketing.
There are genius rock stars, and there are
some agencies who have
got genius rock stars,
who can do amazing stuff
around SC optimization,
search engine optimization,
all these sort of things,
social listening, social media.
But that's a great area
where you can be involved,
over see it, set the direction,
set the mile stones and all that stuff.
But bring in external people.
But I would think the thing you
have to keep hold of, Paula,
is the essence of the customer,
and keeping that customer absolutely.
I wouldn't advocate that you outsource
or bring in third parties to do that.
'Cause that's going to be always critical
to you having that customer experience
and the advocacy that you can get.
- I think if you're looking
at building on a team,
that's an exciting part
as an entrepreneur.
The first thing I'd actually do is
before looking at hiring
somebody, I would look at,
what are the tasks that I'm great at,
and where do I want to
spend most of my time
that I am genius-level talent at?
And that's where I need to
spend as much time as I can,
and then bring people on to support it.
But even before hiring I would look at,
can I automate some of
the things in my business?
Like, it's insane how many people
still use Excel to do their accounting.
Just get accounting software,
it's going to save so much time.
And that sounds self-serving,
doing what we're doing here,
but it's 100% true.
Like, a lot of the tasks that you're doing
should just be automated
and not given to somebody.
When you are thinking
of bringing somebody on,
you've identified the tasks that need
to get done in the business,
that can't be automated,
that has to go to a person,
but it shouldn't be you
'cause you want to spend your time
doing these higher level things.
Those tasks are what you want to delegate.
And then when you bring them on,
you have to understand
that now you're a leader.
You're managing a human being.
It's not just, this happens
to so many entrepreneurs,
they hire the wrong person 'cause it's not
a good values fit as well.
You think, okay I bring this person on,
they're going to save
all this time for me,
I'm going to off load all my work to them.
And then you don't guide them,
and you don't make time for them.
The first month of working
with them is going to take
a lot of your time to train
them, and manage them,
and understand them, and guide them.
And so recognizing that your
role is now going to be a leader,
and helping that person
reach their potential
is much more than just them
accomplishing them tasks
that will save you time,
is super, super important.
How much time do you think--
- Another thing is, Paula--
- Yeah.
No, no go for it.
- Just, sorry, sorry Evan.
Just two other things, really.
Is I'd always advocate,
especially when you start
early stage of the company,
that you bring in, if you're
some marketing individual
or someone to help with the automation,
cash flow box, and all that sort of stuff.
Try and maybe it's one
day every two weeks.
So you don't kind of jump
into it with both feet.
And the other thing I'd always say
is it's a really cool thing,
if you're going to look
at someone on sales
and marketing for your business,
it'd be a really cool thing
to, we call them interim,
so bring someone in on an interim
contract for three months,
and if they work out,
and it'd be really good,
then make them permanent.
So, you can have these sort
of interim to permanent roles.
And just the concept there
is try before you buy.
So, Evan's right, when
you bring someone new
you want them to express the essence
as if they were you, Paula.
And that's very powerful.
And live your values,
all those sort of things.
And a great way, the
only way to find that,
and you can't do that
through interviews and stuff
or references really, it's hard.
And recruitment, you know
this, when you're kind of
starting a company, you
hire your first five people,
you don't probably get
it right all the time.
And it really slows you
down, you can cost yourself
twelve months on these sort of things.
So, a pretty cool way of doing
it is try before you buy.
Or for even a two week trial period.
And then you do find
out when you give them
some real work to do if
they share your values
and share your dreams and can deliver
the acceleration you want
and expand your business.
- I love it.
What is the onboarding
process look like at Sage?
Like somebody's been hired, you go through
the job interview process.
Okay, day one in terms of training
and introducing to the
team and getting involved,
what does onboarding look like for you?
- Everybody gets the one day.
So all colleagues come in and get one day,
and they either get flown
up to Atlanta or Big Hubs
in the UK, where we
get everybody together,
typically on the first
Monday of every month.
And that's the one day, and that's about
the history of the
company, what we care about
in terms of our customers,
a bit about the products,
and then a lot of culture values,
and where to go sort of
thing, so they find it.
When they leave that, they should be able
to navigate 'round the company
and know where people are
and what we really care
about around customers.
Then for managers they get three days.
And they get things like
digital development,
and all that sort of
stuff that's part of that.
And then for sales people
and product people,
they typically get five days.
So, I'll be honest Evan, it's an area
where I think we could do a lot better.
I think if we have this
conversation in three years time,
you'll probably find in Sage,
we'd want to invest probably three days
for all our colleagues
joining at that stage.
'Cause I think, Paula, the other thing is,
it's so easy to hire someone,
you get 'em a coffee,
you say, there you go, here's
a laptop, and off you go.
I would absolutely beg you
to invest at least a minimum
in the morning, and tell 'em
about what your beliefs are,
your ideas, your values, what do you want
to do with customers, you know.
And then break all that down and say,
and the next 30 days I think
we have to do these things,
and the next 90 days we have to do,
so there are very much results
around what matters for customers.
But it is work just taking that time out,
even though it's crazy, and it's busy,
just to really onboard 'em,
and get them aligned with
your way of thinking.
- I love it.
Alright, next.
Peter: "Hey Evan and
Stephen, what technology
"or programs would you
recommend to stand out
"from the rest in customer service?"
- Oh wow, Peter, this is,
so I think around customer service there's
some companies who do this
typically pretty badly,
so the people who have done
this badly maybe invested
billions in, is typically
banking and financial services.
So U.S. data, and now I think
the same with European data,
only 38% of banks' customers
feel that they're valued or
rewarded for their custom.
So, that's the bad situation.
And to Evan's point
around resourcefulness,
and they've spent billions.
Now, what I would say on the positive
is there's some really cool technology.
I've talked about social listening,
there's some really
amazing start up companies,
actually a few that we've
used internally around
taking the pulse of
customers, and you can do,
what I'd advocate the future is all about,
taking the pulse at every interaction.
And customers are more
and more used to this.
And when you kind of build your
system of customer journey,
it's really important at every stage
that you try and exceed
their expectations.
So, it's kind of not a one
hit, one size fits all.
It is a very much a journey,
and I think there's technology I've,
actually a company we've
been using, Rant and Rave,
good name there, Rant and Rave,
is a company where they do pulsing
of customers and real time feedback,
and also all the storing of...
We use methodology internally,
it's a big step forward,
but it's not the end game,
it's called Net Promoter
Scores, and people call it NPS,
and it's really simple, it's
basically would you recommend
this to your friends and
other people in your..
And they're either advocates,
and they'd recommend it,
or they're neutral, or they're detractors.
So, it's quite a pretty simple measure.
And I think the simplicity and the beauty
of these sort of tools are
when they actually grab
the sentiment at every
stage of the journey,
and when they make it really
simple that you can have
actionable content that
you can deliver on.
Therefore obviously,
Peter, the value you get
is when you can change your process
or how you handle a customer's situation,
how they take your products,
it could be anything.
It could be the packaging on the products,
it could be any aspect of the experience
that matters to them.
But it's really useful
for us as entrepreneurs
to know how do we change
it, how do we improve it.
And then also test drive
it with a new prototype,
and then also get new feedback.
- I like it.
I think to add to it I would say,
a lot of the, from a
technology perspective,
a lot of the interactions
are even behind the scenes.
You know, things like
making your website faster
so I have a better experience visiting it.
Things like does it take 25 steps to
buy your product or get in touch with you.
It's a lot of the stuff that
people want it automated,
you want to save them
time, so look through
all your processes and think,
can I make this better?
I would also say, at the core of it,
at some point there's going to be
an interaction with a human being.
You can only automate so much.
When somebody has a
problem or somebody wants
to say thank you or
somebody has a question,
they want to be able
to reach a human being.
And personally for me it drives me nuts
when I have to call in to a help line,
and then it's like, press
one of these five options,
and then one of these two options,
it's like you're cycled
through this 20 step process
before you actually get
to talk to a human being.
And so I would just look at what can I do
to make the human interaction better.
And sometimes the answer's
just get more people,
as opposed to scale the technology.
Like I look at my YouTube
channel as an example,
we get hundreds of comments everyday,
and I want everybody to get a response.
And I don't want an automated response
that goes to everyone that says
thank you for commenting,
thank you for commenting.
I want a human being to respond.
And so, I've hired two people on my team,
and that's their job is
they go through the comments everyday,
and they respond to everybody,
and they save the ones that
I need to see for me as well,
'cause I don't have
the time to go through,
it's like two people's full time job.
And so sometimes the answer's
just scaling people as well.
And the technology that
you bring on should be
to make the jobs of your people easier
to be able to have those interactions.
- So Evan, a question for you is,
with those two guys you brought on,
is how do you get them
to answer the questions
as if they were Evan?
- Uhh.
- What do you invest in them?
When they joined, how did
you sit them down and say,
this is my philosophy?
What did you do about that?
- So, my hiring process already eliminates
most of the people who wouldn't be a fit.
It'll start off with, "I'm
looking for customer service rep
"who believes in entrepreneurs,"
and the first two paragraphs
would all be about the mission.
And some people will look at that and say,
that's the stupidest thing ever.
It's like, great!
We're not going to get along.
This is not going to be a good fit.
Please don't apply, because we're going to
both be wasting our time.
And so a lot of the non-believers
are already kind of filtered out.
From there I just look
at, obviously people
that understand the context, you know,
English language writing
properly, all that kind of stuff.
But I don't have them respond as me.
They always put their name at the end.
I don't want people thinking
that I'm responding when it's not me.
And so they always put
their name at the end.
But they believe in belief.
They believe in the mission.
They don't always say it the
same way that I would say it,
often times they're a
lot nicer than I would be
to somebody who's leaving a comment.
And so I want them to be themselves
but still belief in a mission.
I think if you turn people into robots,
then they're going to act like robots.
Where I want people to
believe in what I believe,
and then use their
judgment and their heart
to solve it as they would solve it.
And it's always worked out.
And then they save the
ones that I need to see,
suggestions for the channel,
complaints about something that I did,
that's good feedback for me to be able
to apply and learn from.
- That's really good,
and I think that's really
authentic as well, Evan.
The other thing for Peter
is, if it's like a product
that you have, then
I'd absolutely advocate
within your early customers you create
some sort of earlier adopter program.
And this is a program where you
directly get your customers,
like Evan said on the website,
it's so easy when we have an idea.
We might not be amazing website designers,
but you've got to put yourselves
in the shoes of the customers.
So, what better way to do that
than have an early adopter program
where you get your customers
to give you real time feedback,
maybe with Skype, on what experience
they're getting on the website,
and you just take 'em through it.
And there's loads of ways
you can reward 'em for that.
And it makes your customers
feel really special.
So, I would constantly
innovate your product through,
and your customer service obviously,
through getting direct
customer sentiment and feeling,
real time through some sort of structured,
early adopter program that
the customers typically,
I've found, love to be involved in.
- Love it.
Next up is Joy: "Sometimes
it's hard to keep up with
"all the different customer questions.
"How do you know how to prioritize?"
- That's a great question, Joy.
And I think you've got to,
there's probably two categories,
there's stuff where it's
just a one-line answer.
And actually what I find,
particularly when things get crazy,
and the volumes just go spike,
some entrepreneurs, and this
is quite naturally human,
can just freeze and they think, oh my,
OMG, how do I handle this stuff?
And typically, we use JDI, just do it.
So there's some stuff, you
probably 50 or even 80%,
you can just carve them out and just say
one-line response, boom,
and it's put to bed.
And it takes a lot of the noise out of it.
And then I think there's
kind of two categories,
there's one category, and it's almost like
a sort of two-dimensional chart,
where you've got something
that's really important,
and the other dimension is urgency.
Timeliness and urgency.
And I think as entrepreneurs
we often spend a lot of time
on non-important stuff
that seems to be urgent.
And what we should do is really prioritize
the really important stuff.
So, is it a new customer that's
going to drive more revenue,
or be a big, maybe it's
a rock star customer,
who's going to be a big reference,
who's a poster child in their industry.
Wow, if that's the case,
that's really important.
And then you need to determine,
once you've determined
the level of importance,
and that's a nano-second
decision that takes two seconds,
is literally then, on
the level of urgency,
and then prioritize it according into
the most important, most urgent.
And there could be important stuff,
but it might not be
time critical for today,
and you can do that in 30, 60, 90 days.
So, I'd just apply that
sort of lens to the inbound
to give you the clarity,
the prioritization.
- I like it.
I would add, if you're getting overwhelmed
by how many emails are coming in,
I would look at it, is my process okay?
Can I just make my website more clear?
So that I don't get as many,
'cause people don't want to
write in with a question.
They don't want to write
in asking for help.
So, can you make your process better?
Because for every one
person who does write in,
there's another ten who just don't bother,
they don't want to spend the time.
And so if you make your process better,
then you won't have to
deal with as much inbound.
I think to then handle the rest of them,
you have to identify what your
priorities are as a company,
here's where we want to grow,
and here's how it fits in,
and if you're getting asked the same thing
over and over and over and over again,
hey, maybe that's the indication that
this is a new thing we should add.
I'm sure at Sage people write
in all the time and say,
hey, it'd be great to add this
feature, and this feature,
and we'd love to see
this, and can you include.
Everybody has their opinions on
how you should run your company.
You know, in their own
best interest, of course.
And I think collecting
that feedback is important.
Obviously, Sage is not going
to include every single feature
that everybody has on their minds.
But if you get the same thing
coming over and over again,
that can help prioritize and say, hey,
a good percentage of our customers
are asking this question,
how do we pick the topics
for these sessions, right?
Like a number of you have
similar kind of topics,
suggestions in mind,
and so the one that is
kind of most popular, that's
what we go with for the next one.
I think too though, also the people who,
just letting people know where they're at,
letting people know what
the realistic chance
of that happening are,
and just having some empathy for them.
For people who want my channels
translated into Spanish,
you know, something we
get asked all the time.
It's something that's on my radar,
but it's not an immediate priority for me.
And so I write back to them and say,
thank you so much for the love,
and I would love to be
able to create this content
for you in Spanish so that you
could understand it better,
and grow your business in
whatever country you're in.
It's just not at the top
of my priority list yet,
but the fact that you brought
it up, I'm going to remember it,
and hopefully one day we'll get to it.
Just recognizing them as opposed to
them feeling like they're totally lost,
even if they're never
going to get the thing
that they're asking for,
I think is important.
And I think that's the way to stand out,
back to the kind of topic
we're covering today,
standing out with your customers,
I think it's really important.
There must be tons of people
who write into Sage saying
like, can you write this
feature and this feature.
- Yeah, tens of thousands.
And with that we have
sort of formal process,
and it's kind of this,
we call it basically,
the product marketeers
and management, anybody.
And we love it.
Well, actually I'd advocate
that I think, Evan and I,
the more feedback we get
from customers, the better.
Good, bad, indifferent, whatever it is,
feedback is golden nuggets,
is absolutely magical.
So, I'd absolutely advocate,
and I think with social media,
social antenna, there's brilliant
ways to get feedback now.
And then you got to act on it.
And you're right, you're absolutely right,
Joy, you've got to prioritize it.
And I think to Evan and his point,
people just value the honesty.
If you say, that's important
but we can't do that
for the next year or so,
they appreciate that.
And then the important thing
is to put a process in to say,
that'll remind on your
Google Calender or whatever,
in a year's time, friend them back to say,
we're ready to do it now.
Or actually it's another six months away.
People just like to be kept in touch.
- I love it.
So speaking of feedback, you're launching
your vlog later on today.
- [Stephen] Yeah.
- We'll link it up,
'cause it's not live yet,
but when it goes live, we'll
link up in the description.
What kind of feedback
do you want from people
on watching your first episode
of the Stephen Kelly Vlog?
- Yeah, I think my purpose is two-fold.
One is to make it useful for the audience.
So, you can very quickly, guys out there,
just tell me is this useful or not.
And secondly, I want you to enjoy it.
I want you to have fun.
And watch it, and enjoy it, and think,
oh, this is five minute of my time that's,
yeah, it's good fun, I like it,
and I got just one nugget
or one idea out of it.
That's great.
So, usefulness and enjoyment is important.
And what would do us is
thinking about this, Evan,
is when we're in Toronto in,
actually at Sage Summit
at the back end of June,
I don't know if they
guys are working on this,
but we should do some fun
stuff, me and you for the vlog.
We should do some, I'm maybe
going up the CNN tower,
do some stuff there that
we could do that's fun.
And also showcases your great
city as well, we love that.
- I'm excited, I'm always down for that.
So, we're at an hour.
It's crazy how quickly it goes.
Guys, and next time
we're coming to you live,
it'll be together, me and
Stephen, at the end of June.
So that'll be fun.
Stephen, kind of final
words to wrap this up
and put a bow on it for the audience?
- Yeah, I just think something
that pulls all together,
this is totally random
how this has happened,
but one of our customers, Kitti Murray,
who's the founder of
Refuge Coffee Company.
She's given this quote where
it sort of says it all,
"We believe in doing things that matter,
"with people instead of for them."
When you do things for people, you affirm
their inherent dignity and value.
You bring them into the
decision making table,
and you make them feel very part of it.
And that's why we do
things with our customers.
Always with.
- I like it.
You might be starting the
trend of now having to end
every show with a quote
as well as start, Stephen.
People are going to like those.
(laughing)
Well, thank you guys.
- Well we got to stand out.
Evan, I've really enjoyed it.
You keep standing out, everybody there.
- Thank you guys for watching,
we'll see you at the end of June.
Continue to believe, and thank
you for tuning in to watch.
- Great show, thanks!
I love that, too.